the Disney Plus original series a
Mandalorian is a massive hit and its
fans have had about two million
questions about the series breakout star
we're not entirely sure that deal with
baby Yoda is but here's everything we
know so far
Yoda species is extremely mysterious
George Lucas famously never gave it a
name wishing the Wizards Jedi Master to
remain an enigma in as many ways as
possible one thing we do know however is
that members of this race are not
asexual as illustrated by Star Wars
Episode one The Phantom Menace the film
gave us a few fleeting glimpses of yah
doll a female member of Yoda species he
was a member of the high Jedi Council
and even assisted in the training of a
young qui-gon jinn while the Mandalorian
doesn't go out of its way to clue us in
as to the gender of baby Yoda
dr. Pershing an employee of the client
reveals the truth in the series third
episode I protected if it wasn't for me
he would already be dead and the little
tyke is referred to as he's several
times in Episode four and a mirror I
even calls him the Mandalorians boy so
at least one mystery has been solved for
sure
baby Yoda is a baby boy with that out of
the way let's move on to a question that
might sound silly at first is baby Yoda
actually the Oder we all know and love
after all the Jedi Master was a baby
once and it was certainly explain a
little guys importance for the remnants
of the Empire and the rebellion alike of
course giving this question a few
moments sort produces an obvious answer
no way at least not unless your species
practices reincarnation the Mandalorian
takes place between the events of the
original Star Wars trilogy and the
sequel films and you may remember that
Yoda became one with the force and died
during the events of Return of the Jedi
well we suppose it's possible that the
series could throw us a curveball with
an actual Yoda and an infant's body
reveal nothing in the show's plotting
thus far indicates to be frank that it
would take a route that's quite so lazy
no we're pretty sure that a new
character baby Oda is the reincarnation
of Yoda he is not of course is another
possibility that baby Yoda could be a
clone of the late Jedi Master it's been
pointed out by astute fans and a
promotional image featuring dr. Pershing
he appears to be wearing a patch with an
Signia that is very very similar to
those warm weather clones of Jango
Fett's produced on the planets Kamino
I've seen an attack of the clones this
could be a coincidence
it could be misdirection or it could be
a dead giveaway of course if the little
dude isn't Yoda this raises the question
what is his name yes we can all be
pretty sure that the internet would have
initially named him baby Yoda in any
events but only continues to do so
because we haven't been clued into what
his real name is have we the answer no
we have not according to Dave Filoni who
directed the 1st and 5th episodes of the
Mandalorians first season this is by
design speaking with Entertainment
Tonight for Loney said we still want to
keep a lot of things a mystery we don't
want to go around answering things and
making them less special told that
people are simply referring to the
Tartus baby Yoda for lack of anything
else to call him baloney replied quote
that's fine all part of the mystery well
that clears up nothing but since we
haven't even got official confirmation
of the Mandalorians name yet we suppose
that shouldn't be too surprising one of
the most dramatic moments in the
mandalorian so far came in the second
episode when mando is nearly killed by a
vicious mud horn we ording nothing but a
knife the Mandalorian lowers his head is
a beast charges but the charge is
interrupted by baby Yoda who uses a
force to levitate the snarling monster
allowing them under Lorien to finish it
off so how the heck is an infant able to
use the Force doesn't that require super
intensive training well yes and no don't
forget that as revealed by the Phantom
Menace children can indeed be force
sensitive and sap into its power with
little to no training
consider Anakin Skywalker whose status
is one of the best pod races in the
galaxy as a mere Yuengling was thanks to
his insane midi-chlorian count even
higher the master Yoda as we recall
obi-wan Kenobi saying sure
Anakin wasn't levitating stuff as a
child but we find it highly likely that
members of Yoda species are naturally
force sensitive taking into account that
the only two to be introduced prior to
baby Yoda's arrival were both esteemed
jedi masters until the Mandalorian gives
us a better explanation for the little
guys Force abilities anyway that's the
best one we've got with the release of
Star Wars Episode nine the rise of
Skywalker
swiftly approaching fans of obviously
taken to wondering if the cute and
cuddly characters introduction in the
Mandalorian is setting us up for an
appearance and a Skywalker sagas
conclusion since the series takes place
sometime before the events of the sequel
trilogy it could be that by the time of
the events of rise of Skywalker baby
Yoda would be well we're not sure kid
Yoda tween Yoda perhaps old enough at
any rate to potentially play a key part
in the story however we find this to be
highly unlikely there's no evidence that
the Mandalorians creator and the writer
jon favreau has coordinated in any way
shape or form with skywalker writer
director JJ Abrams and a young Yoda
cameo well likely a crowd-pleaser
would be off the charts distracting not
to mention shoehorned in considering
what we know about the plot of skywalker
no we're thinking that baby yoda will be
a character specific to the Mandalorian
and that's just fine by us
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]